-Welcome, welcome, welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You are here. You made it. Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, last night was the 65th annual Grammy Awards.
And I -- I love the Grammys.
Where else can you see Beyoncé and Taylor Swift together?
You know?
Ticketmaster's like,
"We can't even make one of those things happen.
[ Laughter ]
That's how hard it is."
This year's Grammy ceremony lasted nearly four hours.
-Ooh. -That's dangerous.
I'll tell you why.
Because every CBS viewer knows
that if it lasts longer than four hours,
they should call their doctor. That's what...
The Grammys lasted almost four hours,
although an hour of that was just stalling
until Beyoncé showed up.
I don't know if you saw this. This was crazy.
Beyoncé couldn't accept her first award
because she was stuck in traffic.
Yeah, I mean, at this point, I'm surprised she didn't just
get out and part the sea of cars like Moses.
I mean, it's Beyoncé.
Seriously, if you think your job is stressful,
imagine being the limo driver who got Beyoncé stuck in traffic
on the night she's making history.
That's right. Beyoncé won her 32nd award,
becoming the most decorated artist in Grammys history.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep, she's the only person who gets her steps in
at an awards show.
It's like, "Yep. Yeah. I hit 10,000. There you go."
Switching gears, everyone's still talking about this.
Over the weekend, U.S. military fighter jets
shot down a Chinese spy balloon over the Atlantic Ocean.
And this is fun. Instead of a medal,
the pilot who popped the balloon
got to pick any stuffed animal on the top shelf.
[ Laughter ]
"I'll take the SpongeB--
You know what? I'll take Bluey. I like Bluey."
Yeah, the balloon floated from Montana to South Carolina.
Somehow it got across the country faster
than someone flying Southwest, but it...
But the U.S. really didn't have a choice.
The only other option was to rub the balloon
on Bernie Sanders and stick it to Canada.
[ Laughter ]
Some more big news.
Tomorrow night, President Biden
will deliver his State of the Union address.
And today he tweeted a photo of his speech
with the caption, "Getting ready."
Yeah, every time he nails a sentence,
he gets a cookie, apparently.
[ Laughter ]
"Give him a cookie."
Apparently, Biden is writing his speech and waiting for Santa.
It's kind of interesting. Some business news.
I saw that next year, Apple could introduce
a more expensive iPhone called the Ultra.
-Ooh. -Yep.
This one will have two flashlights
that turn on in your pocket.
-Ohh!
-Of course, you've got to take better care
of a more expensive iPhone.
If you drop this one in the toilet,
you have to put it in a bowl of risotto.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on! -Thank you, thank you.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
This -- Some movie news.
This weekend, "Knock at the Cabin"
beat "Avatar: The Way of Water" at the box office.
Yeah, the movie's a huge success.
They've already come up with a few sequels.
-Really? -Yeah.
After "Knock at the Cabin," they're going to release
"Knock, Knock at the Cabin."
Then...
Followed by...
Finally...
"I didn't say banana at the cabin."
[ Applause ]
Did you guys see this?
AMC announced that they're going to start charging
different prices for tickets
based on where you're sitting in the theater.
[ Audience groans ]
I'm not sure about this.
I mean, it's rough when you're in boarding group D
for "Puss in Boots." You know? You go...
Some sports news. The Super Bowl is this Sunday.
[ Cheers and applause ] Yeah, that's right.
-Chiefs!
-I read that this year the broadcast
will have even more alcohol ads than usual.
Finally, a chance to make football fans aware of alcohol.
Guys, I heard about the founder of Spotify.
He helped create a body scanner that can detect the growth
of things like rashes and birthmarks.
Damn. It sounds like the real Spotify.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on!
Come on! That's two!
Wow! -Yeah, and this is cool.
At the end of the year, they're going to make
all your skin tags into a Coachella poster.
Meanwhile, if your rash has grown,
the Spotify scanner just plays this.
-♪ You know it's not the same as it was ♪
[ Applause ]
Finally, guys, it's Monday, and I think we all could use
a little encouragement to make it through
the rest of the week. Don't you feel that way?
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's time for some "Monday Motivations."
Here we go.
♪♪
You look amazing in that shirt.
Trust me. You're gonna have the best week.
When you go to the zoo, everyone's like,
"Wow. What a beautiful specimen."
And they're not talking about the animals.
On day one of planning her world tour,
Beyoncé sat down and was like, "So where does Abby live?"
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
When you agree to see a dessert menu,
the waiter is like, "Yay. You're staying."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
You can feel this one?
The day you got your braces off, your orthodontist was like,
"Oh, God. What if I never see her again?"
[ Applause ]
When you get pit stains, everyone's like,
"A shirt with polka dots in the armpits? I love that."
[ Laughter and applause ]
When you click "book flight" online,
the President of Costa Rica is like,
"O-M-G, guys! Emily's coming! Emily's coming!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, when your phone dies, it's like,
"My one regret is not spending more time with you."